how's it going Wolfgang as I mentioned
in my video earlier today we have a lot
of new information and a few new leaks
in the DC EU and the MCU today and one
of those leaks is regarding Wonder Woman
1984 a fan was actually on set and
managed to sneak in some footage of the
filming of a couple scenes in Wonder
Woman 2 she managed to get some footage
of a couple of scenes but I think the
greatest thing that she captured was
Chris Pine actually noticed her
recording and what does he do he
actually teases her about it as you can
see here Chris Pine is walking with
director patty Jenkins and Wonder Woman
gal gadot and he notices her filming
then he throws up his hands and he acts
like he's filming her she kind of starts
freaking out a bit because he notices
her and obviously she's a fan and then
what does he do he sees her he waves and
he's like I see you I see you recording
I see you recording this scene that
you're not supposed to be recording
right now and he does it again I see you
I see you recording
gobby doe kind of turns around and
wonders what he's doing she kind of sees
the camera and turns around doesn't want
to deal with it but the greatest part is
in this next clip he does it again he
puts his hands up and gal gadot turns
around was like what are you looking at
sees the person filming kind of turned
her back and starts walking away doesn't
want to deal with it this person is
obviously not supposed to be filming
this but the greatest part is that Chris
Pine motions to her to throw her phone
away I mean to me it's hilarious
she knows she's not supposed to be
filming and Chris Pine is kind of being
cool about it just saying like hey take
that phone throw it out of here you're
not supposed to be doing that they
obviously don't want anything leaked and
I guess I'm kind of furthering the
problem by doing a video on this sorry
but there is actually real footage of an
actual scene and I don't know where they
are but Chris Pine Steve Trevor and gal
gadot Wonder Woman Diana Prince there
looks like they're outside somewhere but
they run into a few break dancers and
Steve Trevor is a little taken back you
can see him heat
notices um takes a step back almost like
these guys gonna fight like they're
doing a lot of moving what's going on
then you can see starts kind of not in
his head because there's clearly music
plan and what it really seems like here
is he is not supposed to be in the 80s
Wonder Woman 1984 takes place in 1984
and Diana's a god she doesn't age so
that leaves a question how does Steve
Trevor
in the 80s he clearly did not live all
the way until the 90s maybe he was
frozen or something maybe he's brought
back to life somehow but he clearly has
no idea what's going on but Diana does
this to me seems like they just reunited
and he has no idea what's going on in
the 80s because he's either been like
frozen or something and she's just kind
of casually explained to him it kind of
seems like she's having a hard time
soaking this in as well so she clearly
didn't know that he was alive or being
reserved this whole entire time until
1984 I'm almost wondering if this is
gonna be sort of a Steve Rogers Captain
America thing where you know he gets
frozen so maybe Steve Trevor finds a
parachute in the plane at the end of one
Romo tooth jumps out lands in the snow
like on top of a mountain or something
somehow and gets frozen or maybe another
God somehow preserved him or saved his
life for Diana somehow he was preserved
because he clearly didn't live from 1917
to 1984 so it leaves us with the
question what happened how did Steve
Trevor survive the explosion in the
plane from the first Wonder Woman movie
and how was he preserved for 67 years
let me know your thoughts and theories
in the comments below
genuinely interested because I'm very
curious as to what story they're gonna
go with here please click the thumbs up
button if you enjoyed this video and
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on Wonder Woman 1984 DC Marvel and
all things superhero thank you so much
for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
[Music]